معنى الانا من رام الله مراسااء جزيره
سمير ابو شماله اذا ضعنا في صوره اخر
تطورات هذا الخبر سمير حسبما وصلكم
نعم ايمان الجيش الاسرائيلي قبل لحظات كان
هناك له بيان مقتضب وقصير تحدث به بان
هناك مجموعه من المسلحين كانوا يستقلون
مركبه تحمل لوحه ترخيص فلسطينيه قد اطلقت
الرصاص على احدى المركبات التي يستقلها
احد المستوطنين وهو شاب يبلغ من العمر 25
عاما قربه مفترق بيت عربات على شارع رقم
تسعين القريب من البحر الميت وقد اطلق
الرصاص على هذه المركبه ما ادى الى اصابه
المستوطن بجروح وصفت وفقا للمصادر الطبيه
الاسرائيليه بالحرجه جدا ومن تم تم
المواصله هذه المجموعه
باتجاه مستوطنتي او مفرق مستوطنه جنوب
مدينه اريحا
واطلقوا الرصاص على سياره اخرى كانت تقل
العائله من المستوطنين ولكن الرصاص لم يصب
العائله ولكنه اصاب المركبه ذاتها ولكن لم
يبلغ عن وقوع عصابات في هذه في هذه الهجمه
الثانيه وقد فر المسلحون حسب بيان جيش
الاحتلال الى مدينه اريحا وقد كان هناك
ملاحقه من قبل قوات من شرطه الاحتلال
وقوات الجيش التي حاصرت وطوقت واغلقت جميع
المداخل والمخارج المؤديه الى مدينه اريحا
في اشتباه بان المسلحين او المسلح حسب
التقديرات الاخرى بانه قد فر ولد بالفرار
الى مدينه اريحا للاختباء بعد ان نفذ هذه
الهجمات او هذه العمليه ولكن هناك ايضا
وسائل الاعلام اسرائيليه تتحدث عن انه عند
انسحاب الشبان او هذه الخليه قد احرقت
المركبه التي كانت تقلهم وقد انسحبوا سيرا
على الاقدام في المناطق القريبه من مدينه
اريحا وهناك عمليات تفتيش وتمشيط واسعه
النطاق من قبل قوات جيش الاحتلال في محيط
مدينه اريحا بعد اغلاق جميع المداخل
والمخارج الخاصه بالمدينه وذلك بحثا عن
منافذي هذا الهجوم